art we talk a lot about 1 percent on the
show and an interesting study came out
by say top investment
research breaking down some but the
economics what's going on in america
today
so this is from 2012 the average
household income americans
is about thirty thousand dollars the
average household
at the top one percent uRS is about 1.2
million
which is 41 times the average family's
income the average household up the top
.1 percent
is about six million which is 200
and six times the average family income
so i think is interesting about this
is that you know when you think you're
the one percent I think people think
this is these are the people that have
like
you know an armada of plane that houses
everywhere tear tear
now they do have over a million bucks
which i think probably what we all
aspire to have been this is America
everybody's having but should we be
focusing more on that point one percent
than the 1 percent because that point
when that fix me that sorta we getting
into the
alter it although he did that is still
leaving out all the
sucker birds and the people that really
have the big power
given me a lot to chew on their well I
don't know where to begin I never think
about the point per cent 1 percent 02 I
mean
I could just get so like after it that
number gets a large is a good actually
meeting with to me it's like to make
69er migrate could be six billion
I a really good so ridiculous my first
thought was like
well you know within like on Obama's
watch I'm like well I get the only good
information its if it was a
on a republicans what we'll be talking
about the point 001
making 12 million a year something like
that universally
so much you can do but at the end of the
day ever into the sweet notions that
like
all our country was founded on democracy
its capitalism I mean capitalism trumped
democracy and you can't really blame
people
for going in you know into these money
markets into these hedge fund jobs they
wanna make a lotta money that's their
thing and they make a lot of money and
it's like
its it's really hard point you just hope
that they
at the other day hope that they give
back right that you're making all this
money
that maybe you can take it you know your
personal wealth and do good things with
it
and if you don't you just hope you know
that they're miserable you know that
there are four
visible people are they ever miserable
back to quell
there never have a nice day six million
dollars
suppers 10 I look it it the
if that is the things that you remember
when Warren Buffett was saying at one
point I think when they pick on was
crashing that
based on the taxes he was paying because
a lot of his income was up with
investments
his pain like I'm like a 15 percent rate
whereas like
like normal people pain like 30-40
percent say he was making a point about
that first of all
about you know nothing of taxing the
rich a little bit more and finding ways
to get money from them in the other
things I just heard yesterday
it was saying some company for you with
the company was why these big companies
caterpillar with caterpillar was the
underpaid like two billion dollars in
taxes or something because they found
ways to do it
they they moved all their profits to to
a Swiss bank account yes unless we go if
we get upset you gonna do it like I
you know and I'm paying every dollar I
Megan paying fifty cents
a that to the government and there's
these big companies are finding
loopholes
yeah that's where you go come on man in
Alajuela spread a little bit I well
I always look at the Warren Buffett
thing was kind if you think as you know
he say well my
the secretaries paying a higher tax then
I am which always maybe they will buy
you painter so little
your day like if you pay her more than
she did not cause are your tax bracket
paizuri doing a paper with stocks then
then she would pay then then she would
not pay that she pay
less taxes but it's been is income yeah
so that's that's we get screwed yet so
the break that you brought up his butt
this article
that was analyzing this was also saying
is that this gap between the altar rich
and the poor
has gotten significantly bigger under
Obama and I think we think we all think
somehow that if the republicans that are
really bad about this but
this is why these things where Obama has
dropped the ball cuz
the back to the back well I don't know
he's dropped the ball I just don't know
how much
he can do you know in a way it's like
you do you talk about Wall Street
perform a wall street that money
fuel for lobbyists new fuels congress
like there's only so much
you're gonna do to stop this money you
know what I mean I just feel like
its you know its it's like that thing
when it when they're like Oh praise a
run for president you know you like the
most popular woman on the planet she's a
cool why would I give up all that power
where they remain yeah I don't look like
an idiot and black blame Obama conflate
I mean on Obama's election night all the
big wig republicans I got Metro Manila
we're gonna do one thing we're gonna
block
everything that he intends to do and may
have
or they've been very successful at that
so I don't know if you can keep going
back to the Obamacare
I don't think they like black people
that but Leicester
know it's this it is naive to think that
one person is going to make
you'll be able to run everything in our
yard is white house of cards he realize
the vice president to be pulling the
string yet you know and there's a lot of
things that are
been a back-door deals being made in as
this is a systemic
thing unfortunately unlike a lot of
other countries
do tax you pay more taxes but you
you know you don't have homeless people
for example shows the choice that we
have to make that we want to pay less
taxes
and have all most people are more taxes
and not have on the street was that
house occurring reference your way of
telling us that you think Biden is
killed someone
I think that I have to kill someone and
it's a great show
the it is a pretty great show I how
should we generally feel
about the super rich people I'm not even
talking about that one percent and
the six million people you know that the
people are bringing in sick man dies he
i'm talking about.
the the real the billionaire billionaire
people should we be at like
this George Soros this we just met with
all the potential
Republican 2016 guys make it like they
have to go kiss the rain here they have
just done a great guy
yeah it's pretty is pretty sick right
well I mean this morning it comes down
to we have now
left you know restrictions on who can
pay hutu
run for election it's just that yellow
brick work yes thank you sir princ
whitewater-related Supreme Court
a so now I can get my you know 10 bucks
the democrats ara it
it's so you know it is when you really
think about it you feel powerless and
it's really hardly discouraging but then
you're like
others assail on wine and that solves a
lot of
a my problems when I think about the
super-rich yet
how do you feel now it's like this and
then if they made the money they want to
do what they want to do they can do it
it's just
I the the one thing you do start
worrying about is if the
the the disparity continues then you
know
if you look at history every revolution
as many religion
is based on a con economics now so
eventually there's going to be a
breaking point
and so I think at some point the the
country does need to step back and go
okay let's
week we can't have that many more people
that are
their poor and this few that are rich
because eventually
something will yakima 106 times the
amount on the average income
these people are making seems like a bit
a hand in the loop holes it is it's
infuriating and now you know it's
unfortunate now everyone's arm so
I mean it literally it could happen it
could happen